[Music]
last year one poignant photo put the
spotlight on service dogs that help our
military veterans
it showed a service dog named Sully at
the foot of the casket of former
President George HW Bush whom he loyally
aided in the final six months of mr.
Bush's life but Sully is just the best
known of the legions of dogs doing this
important work
correspondent Don Dahler got a closer
look and joins us now Don good morning
good morning veterans who survived war
zones can face all kinds of challenges
from traumatic brain injury to PTSD and
these dogs have proven to be both
beloved companions and caregivers on
their road to recovery that includes
Sully who's now back on the job helping
other members of the military
with his gentle devotion to former
President George HW Bush the dog named
Sully won a permanent place in our
hearts but cliff Miller fell in love
with the lab years earlier at just eight
weeks old the pup was chosen by Miller
his partner Patricia summers and their
community service group Friends of
America's vet dogs for a very important
job and gave him a name with special
meaning when we picked him out of the
litter his hair was closest to captain
sullenberger's Sully of course was named
for a man who exhibited heroism in
civilian and military life we chose
Sully to honor captain Chesley
Sullenberger not because of his ability
to save all those people in landing the
plane those particular flying skills
came about when he was a United States
Air Force fighter pilot America's vet
dogs the Long Island based charity that
provides service dogs to veterans
depends on donations from ordinary
people
Miller's group of 25 volunteers raises
more than anyone else I think a lot of
people would be surprised that these
dogs aren't supplied by a grateful
nation to these vets the Vietnam vets
that we're returning from combat back
then we're not it was actually a
disgrace the way the vets were treated
and now is the opportunity that that we
as a group of just friends if they need
a service dog to have a better life we
can actually do something to make that
happen
men and women like Sharon Renier she was
a nurse for 27 years and treated 9/11
victims soon after she enlisted herself
in the Army and was assigned to an
emergency room in Baghdad what was that
like we were having rockets and mortars
lobbed in all the time did you have an
idea then how it was affecting you
emotionally I think it hits you a little
bit later you just become almost robotic
to what's going on after 10 years in the
United States Army Sharon decided it was
time to hang up her uniform and try to
return to civilian life that was not as
easy as it sounds I was put into the
Warrior Transition battalion in Bethesda
because you know I had had a an attempt
in this way an attempt yeah because I
had had so much guilt and so much you
know you know all these things that had
built up she was having trouble
functioning going out in public made her
anxious sleep eluded her or was
interrupted by night terrors but a
chance Hospital encounter changed her
life one of the Boston bombing victims
mark foo Carelli was at Walter Reed he
had a dog comrade and he was just kept
coming to me I just said I think that's
what I need easier said than done
vet dogs cost upwards of $60,000 to
raise train and care for but Sharon was
determined I wanted a dog but little did
I know I was getting better because I
was working for towards his dog so it
was about four months after I actually
retired out of the army that I got the
phone call and I was just like oh that
dog is Eddie a bit of a goofball when
he's not working
Eddie door but all business when he is
the four-year-old brindle Labrador never
leaves her side I woke up and I could
not believe that this was possible but I
have night terrors and Eddie interrupted
my nightmare night terror the first
night I had him and I was like in tears
the next day if he did nothing else for
me but that life was gonna be great
so it's being out like this something
you could have done before Eddie no I
did like I said I used to do a lot a lot
of isolation not any longer
Eddie has opened up the world to her
again getting Sharon out of the house
and into social situations something she
never thought she'd be able to do like
having lunch with her family and as for
that other lab Sully well he now works
at the same hospital where a service dog
showed
there might be a way out of her PTSD
Sully is now part of a team of
rehabilitation dogs at Walter Reed
Medical Center in Bethesda Maryland
Samantha Murdoch is one of Sully's
handlers we have a list of ward patients
where they go out and get visits every
day
he knows certain offices that he likes
to go in and visit people in and certain
wards and clinics that he absolutely
loves they automatically calm you down
they put you back they put things back
in focus right Navy sailor Robert hunter
and they help us so it's really nice
that Walter Reed does this for us and
among many other things Sully and the
other dogs also help military
beneficiaries like eleven-year-old
Camden mcalpine who is diagnosed with a
rare immunity disease dogs come and you
can just like like it just makes you
feel a lot happier to have a dog just
with you it's not always medicine that
heals fully salute yes good boy
sometimes just having a friend can work
miracles
now cliffs group actually names all of
the dogs they sponsor after honorable
military heroes as a way to carry on
those legacies Sharon and Eddie are
hoping to travel soon to bring awareness
to the many issues our current veterans
are facing and as for Sully he'll be
serving patients at Walter Reed for as
long as he can how old is he Sully I
think he's seven or eight I'm not
positive but yeah I mean you you really
understand the power that these dogs can
have when when you with Sharon's story
about how the dog on the first night
will turn her up yeah from from night
tremors I mean that's extraordinary no
they're making people functional human
they are literally saving lives and
Sharon wants to bring attention to the
issue of suicide among veterans that we
talked about it is an enormous problem
and these dogs can really help with it
and there are other groups I know that
do some of the training for the dogs but
the same thing you've got to get money
to them because they're not support it's
not government
but we thank you don we thank you